more of the entertainment world's
biggest celebrities are talking about
their own very personal health stories
in the new Paramount plus series called
the checkup with Dr David Aegis Amy
Schumer Nick Cannon Jane Fonda Lily
Tomlin and others are sharing their
struggles with our Dr David Aegis the
topics include the devastating loss of a
child from brain cancer and reproductive
health issues here's a look at the
newest episodes
did you drink a lot when you were
younger mm-hmm yeah we started drinking
early I started drinking when we were
like 12. really it's a Saturday May 14
1994. my new patient Amy Schumer is
unapologetically honest about her health
from binge drinking I one time came out
of a blackout while I was awake and
there was a guy in my room that I hadn't
that I didn't remember meeting to a
recent plastic surgery and the pregnancy
that nearly broke her it was a full nine
months of being violently ill I didn't
even hear the words hyperemesis until
six months in
hyperemesis gravidarum is a severe and
persistent nausea condition during
pregnancy Amy documented her ordeal and
shared it on social media why did you
say Hey listen everything I go through
I'm going to tell people I feel moved to
share what's going on when I hear about
other people that with my same struggles
I feel better I feel less alone Nick
Cannon opens up about his ongoing battle
lupus and the devastating loss of his
infant son Zen when we took him to the
doctor they noticed that his head was
larger than it should have been at two
months that's when you know he did a lot
of tests they didn't let him leave the
hospital and so you could imagine you'd
think you're taking you know your son
into get a checkup for asthma and to
know that you know he gets diagnosed
with brain cancer that was a shock and
two of the most iconic women in
entertainment Jane Fonda and Lily Tomlin
share a few laughs about aging in season
two of Grace and Frankie you had a
amazing scene where you looked at one of
the issues that was facing women as they
get older people really liked the fact
that we were making vibrators and people
would write us I'm on social media I
would get comments from people that were
very supportive and they really liked
the fact that we we did that many of my
relatives wanted me to send them one
[Music]
CBS News medical contributor Dr David
Aegis joins us now to talk about this
David good morning
good morning to you
a little bit of a delay there so Amy
Schumer who you reveal is your patient
candidly shares with you how violently
ill she felt during her pregnancy she
says she felt alone what do you want
people to take away from this
conversation that you had with them
I just want to normalize these health
issues right I mean she had severe
endometriosis she required a
hysterectomy later on and during
pregnancy she had this condition
hyperemitis gravidarum which is
constantly throwing up and it's not
uncommon and so the more she talks about
it the more we normalize it and we can
have conversations we all have health
issues no matter who we are in the
country
Dr egg is speaking of normalizing the
topic of aging and sex we all had a
little laugh there there's some nervous
laughter in that set up piece what do
you want people to take away from that
conversation with Jane Fonda and Lily
Tomlin
you know these two women who are both
absolutely remarkable talk about how
they've aged well and what they've gone
through you know sex as we get older is
normal we stop talking about it we
pretend it doesn't happen in our parents
and our grandparents but it certainly is
something that if you want to maintain a
vibrant life and be healthy sex is
critical and so having a conversation
open about that is powerful
well can I just say I didn't have
nervous laughter during that part I was
like preach speak David speak Jane speak
Lily and thank you that's what I thought
so I applaud you David
[Laughter]
cue the nervous laughter Dr David
the two guys here just like this oh no
not here I'm like please no is it time
to rap yet
sex is healthy
healthy y'all
uh all right Dr David Angus you could
tell we really are digging this
conversation the checkup with Dr David
agus is streaming now on Paramount plus
which like CBS is a division of
Paramount Club